hello everybody my name is bradley and
today we're going to show you how our
digital jungle tracking systems work you
probably remember that about a month ago
i published a short invitation on
youtube right where you had the
opportunity to participate in a
one-of-a-kind
experiment hello
do you want to play a game
right so throughout the month over 500
people volunteered to have their
personal data dug up and
well examined by our digital jungle
tracking system now the results are in
and you are in for a treat unless
you're one of our subjects and then
you're screwed
[Applause]
[Music]
by the way this video is purely
education in nature i just want to
basically explain how you can properly
hide your information and especially
that that could one day turn against you
i'm not a private detective a police
officer or a secret agent right contrary
to popular belief therefore i don't have
access to special services databases
information brokers or even the youtube
and facebook logs right but i will show
you the techniques with which any
investigation begins i obviously wonder
how close some of these assumptions that
i'm going to make might be to real life
so please let me know in the comments if
you're one of our subjects whether i'm
right or wrong however i reckon i'm a
pretty talented bloke so let's see
i'm ready to participate i'm curious as
to what someone can dig up with just one
of my usernames right so let me
introduce you to our first hero his
nickname is wait what and he's been
using that name since 2013. during this
time our hero has posted four videos
three of which gave me hints as to where
i should start looking so let's start
from the beginning in addition to the
rather unusual arthropods we've got a
very telling date of upload december the
first
now it's unlikely that the author having
youtube channel postponed the
publication of successful shots for
several months i would rather believe
that he posted this video right after he
shot it and also know that spiders
hibernate for the winter therefore in
december it's only gonna be possible to
meet such a beauty in the southern
hemisphere in addition let's take a look
at the size of the spider compare the
size of its feet with the tile this is a
really unusual spider and at first
glance it could be native to either
africa or australia
hello
now the boy that's commenting on what is
happening is speaking english can you
see
[Music]
and it's definitely a native accent but
he's not from england i can't exactly
make out where he's from from his
internation
but the circle definitely begins to
narrow south africa or australia could
certainly be plausible let's watch a
second video it lasts only a second but
the description of it provides us with a
lot of additional information
so a friend of the channel's author
named jaden appears on the screen it's a
pretty low quality video so it's useless
to use services that track down a person
by their photo so instead we'll get an
indication of the place where we should
have looked for this guy back in 2015.
cooper petty
have you ever heard of that city no
probably not me neither i'm not sure if
i'm pronouncing that right but wikipedia
suggests that this is small town in the
central part of australia a lot of opal
mining goes on there among other things
but the main thing of note is that this
population is less than 1 500 people now
you probably couldn't get lost easily i
mean let's be honest
[Music]
therefore if i were a policeman i would
already be drafting messages to my
australian colleagues or more simply you
could just leave a message in a group on
facebook for this town's residence all
you need to do is come up with some
beautiful story about finding a friend
and leave his photo there which we have
surely somebody's going to respond
finally the third video only
strengthened my faith in my search
direction this is a recording of the
work of a russian military radio station
which the author made using a digital
decoder there are thousands of such
recordings to be honest but notice how
wait what indicated the time when he
made it
do you see kst
well this means the korean time zone
what does australia have to do with that
well the northern part of australia
lives with an unusual time shift not by
an hour or two but actually by an hour
and a half therefore so that we don't
confuse residents of other countries
with a shift of 30 minutes australians
often use the korean time zone kst
in the case of the radio station
recording i suppose the understanding of
minutes was more important than the
official time of their country so look
we've got
kuberpedi australia nailed down and a
few messages to residents by facebook
later we'd probably get a name i want a
name
and yet
so if i were a special agent at this
point it would be plain sailing let me
explain
it's clear that way what isn't that
popular on youtube i mean he's only got
16 subscribers this means that the
author probably wasn't that interested
in promoting his channel beyond his
inner circle of friends and family or
maybe other people that would be
interested in his content
therefore one official request to
youtube would allow you to quickly
calculate the author's social circle
with nicknames and ip addresses included
close people who don't care about their
anonymity can give you away therefore
either don't allow people to subscribe
to you full stop or attract as many
people as possible to your youtube
account now it will be much more
difficult to figure out who really knows
you then right
10 or 20 subscribers really is a very
insecure option
i'm ready to participate curious how
much can you find right moving on our
next hero is dj slem we found out a lot
about this guy this guy has a number of
actually quite good electronic mixes on
his youtube channel let's see what we
can find out about him and whether he's
in fact a dj as his name suggests
there's a face on the avatar so this is
a good start i can use an online photo
enlargement tool like this one that i
found offered by codex radar to
basically take a look at that more
carefully there are also tools like this
for instagram so always be careful as to
what you said as your profile picture
because people will always be able to
pull out the full-sized image let's take
a look now all we have to do is put this
photo into a service like tinai and see
what comes up now with this example we
didn't get anything it was a straight
dead end but worth a try because at
least we know what he vaguely looks like
now there's nothing in his about section
so there's nothing really that would
give us additional information in this
case however it does say that his
location is in the netherlands now this
corroborates with the language he uses
in his youtube descriptions dutch
now obviously i don't speak dutch but
all i had to do was use the text
language function on google translate
and you can do this in any language too
which is pretty neat stuff
so the next step here would be to google
everything we have on him dj slem
netherlands and looks like we get a
website straight away let's take a look
at all the tabs and you can see that
there's a link to his youtube channel
here right this is his website
and let's google translate this text
here to find out what it means
so as you can see at the time of
publishing this website he was 14 and to
be honest his music is quite good for a
14 year old i mean check this out
[Music]
i also released some music on soundcloud
when i was 14 but it's not something
that i would want anyone to see ever
anyway this site also took us to a
facebook profile and you can see in the
url that the number 2005 clearly
represents his birth year that would
make sense too as he was 14 when the
site was made or uploaded so now he must
be 16. we've also got a phone number
here so if i were the police it would be
very easy to track him down from here
but we're not the police so let's go
back to his facebook page there really
aren't that many likes at all here so
i'm guessing that these people would be
his friends and family and when we go to
this post exactly which has three likes
we can see that all of these people have
exactly the same last name and this guy
mel's has a picture that's very
recognizable yeah that's the picture
that's on the site next to the about me
segment
so this is our guy mel's
from diddam aged 16.
hi mels and remember all of this data
can be taken from a youtube channel that
does not show your real name that just
displays your photo and your country so
be careful
but hopefully males you get a bit more
publicity for your youtube channel and
your music great stuff anyway look it's
not the smartest idea to use the same
nickname or pseudonym on different
services because it becomes much more of
an identifying factor as opposed to an
anonymizing one right and equally you
shouldn't get carried away with really
unique nicknames
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm ready to participate
smiley face can you translate this word
harlequin
google can this word translates from
estonian into english as crazy
so what can we find out about this
channel's crazy owner
four subscribers and four uploaded
videos this doesn't seem like a lot to
work with but the videos give us a
valuable insight into the hobbies of the
creator computer games and programming
he clearly started a while ago with a
harmless joke program that was written
in java and after just four years he was
programming utility programs for discord
now a good place to start with this guy
would be gaming services and i'll start
of course with the largest gaming
service in the world steam you've just
achieved first blood and look we've
already found the estonian madman
and we know that because the avatars
match
but another country is already indicated
here germany and there's also a name
according to the steam account our
hero's name is leo and most importantly
over the past couple of weeks he has
used steam and judging by his game time
he's been using it more than once
this means that steam's logs can still
contain data about his ip address his
exact usage time and so on now for the
police it would be really plain sailing
from this point
yeah we don't want to do anything to
scare your children that's the last
thing we want to do we don't want to
scare anybody
let me explain if you're gaming it's
very unlikely that you'll opt to use a
vpn most people want to optimize their
internet speed right not hinder it that
means it's very likely that steam has
accurate information about hula kula's
ip address
but i wonder if i can find anything else
about this guy i mean is he estonian or
german
well it would be possible to ask one of
his 96 friends on steam but i'm going to
check his name on other popular games
and services and i seemingly struck gold
with this site for minecraft skins right
check it out our hero turns out to have
changed his name several times he
switched from hula kula to leo 1996
underscore 22. well it looks like his
real name is leo and the number 1996
represents his birth year and to this
day i will never understand why people
choose to use their year of birth in
their online usernames it's so bizarre
it's it's like a kind of
cult to the antichrist of the religion
of anonymity right anyway so this guy's
25 and the profile of the hobbyist
turned serious programmer fits in really
nicely here
so look what if we used this second
nickname somewhere else
well i did and i found a video on
youtube where our hero is spawning
chickens for target practice on
minecraft
i'm probably not even going to comment
on this but just take a look if you want
i can leave a link to it in the comments
but what is interesting from this
however is that this video was posted
from a different channel the author left
some buttons here too for feedback you
could probably also turn to some old
german minecraft forums right and here i
found a forum discussing the utilities
of our leo usually the gaming community
and modders know a lot about each other
and it remains only really to think out
a story and ask for help and here no
high technology is needed social
engineering which i talked about in one
of our previous videos can be used for
instance i could invent some story that
leo and i used to play minecraft on a
server back in the day when we used to
shoot chickens with arrows and maybe i'd
like to get in touch with him on
facebook or instagram and i think i get
his information very easily that way
finally i'd like to tell you about
another interesting viewer of my channel
this man is associated with games much
riskier than leo b-25 from germany
[Music]
i'm ready to participate this will be
very interesting grinning face with
sweat do you guys know what binary
options are well my next hero not only
knows but is also ready to teach you how
to make money on them at least albert k
claims that of the four videos on this
channel my attention was drawn to the
very first one this is not just a clip
but a recording of a live broadcast in
which albert demonstrated his abilities
and as in most of these streams a lot of
interesting things fell on record
firstly it immediately caught my eye
that windows has not been activated i
can't imagine such a problem would exist
within a serious organization and it's
somewhat indecent to use pirated
software at home especially if you're
trying to teach other people how to make
money but i'm not going to blame albert
for that and i'm ready to write it off
as a technical malfunction right we all
make mistakes i mean look he's clearly
trying to legally sort out the problem
with his friend nico on telegram or not
maybe he's just getting more priority
software but the resolution of this
video is low but it allows you to read
our hero's full name in the title of one
of his desktop documents so this is
clearly a gentleman named albert
a quick google later and we found his
mql5 account with a matching picture
according to this profile he's located
in vietnam
interesting and when we dig a little
further we can see we've got a linkedin
result here confirming that he lives in
ho chi minh city and works as an english
teacher
perhaps he taught there as an expat
i would know i personally have taught as
an english teacher expert but also take
a look at the other documents on the
screen there's a document in korean
i wonder whether he traveled as an
english teacher i mean it would make
sense right so i know his name and i
went on facebook and took a look i found
a guy with a similar name but what's
very interesting is that he has checked
into a variety of different places in
asia we've got south korea and cambodia
which as you all know borders vietnam i
guess that this is our guy
but i had a real surprise raising for me
so i decided to check this new name
we've got on facebook this abbreviation
and i found him on vk
now this is a social network very
similar to facebook almost exclusively
used by russians now this profile tells
us his date of birth the 18th of april
1990 which is very probable considering
that he checked into dejean in 2013. i'm
assuming he worked there as an english
teacher and he'd have to be at least 18
to get that working visa it would make
even more sense to assume that at this
point he'd be in his early 20s now the
vk lead allowed us to find the data of
two people who communicated with albert
evgeny a trader from the euros and alexi
both russian now surely these guys could
tell us some more information about our
hero right
[Applause]
[Music]
before we end this i do have some
honourable mentions first of all i'd
like to mention aardash chaudhary in
passing this is the vocalist of a
wonderful band from india and recordings
of his concerts were uploaded by several
fans so now i have access to a small
list of his fans basically i also want
to warn
an account sunny
that through her main blog on blogspot
it's very easy to get access to an
alternative one filled with teenage
experiences and insecurities do you
remember that well we will
so to all the other viewers out there if
you care about your privacy don't use
the same names and avatars on different
services also avoid cross-references
between resources you have different
social circles on different sites and
the bigger network the easier it could
be to attain your residence details your
interests or even to uncover old
mistakes and things that you'd prefer to
forget about anyway my name is bradley
peake and i'd like to thank you for
joining me on another sobering salutary
and superbly scrumptious slide down one
of the many slippery slopes of the
online jungle i will see you in the next
video thanks for joining us
[Music]
by the way guys this was obviously
really surface level stuff we have the
tools and expertise to go far deeper so
if you do like this we're more than
happy to do a part two where we include
a lot more of you in a longer video so
please do let us know by liking
commenting sharing our video and
obviously subscribing thanks a lot for
joining us